so I haven't had a haircut in eight
months Charlie McDonnell presents 21 fun
things for you to do with long hair
provided of course that you have long
hair brush it with a hairbrush ah it
feels so soft
make it as tall as you possibly can chew
on it when you're bored twirl it with
your fingers put some of it in a
hairband yep this is this is on the
internet now so that's good measure it
with a tape measure about 15 centimeters
so there you go
head bang with it until you feel ill huh
shower and then imitate a wet dog use it
to cover up that acne of yours use it to
make a clone of yourself yay use it as a
hiding spot for high-seat all right oh
well there's nothing in here but a pile
of hair it cut a little off and put it
in a scrapbook now I'll always remember
the times that we had use it to shine
your shoes
ha I cleaned it see I cleaned it with my
hand
use it as a helmet to protect yourself
from harm yes I think that would have
hurt much more if I'd had shorter hair
hide secret messages under your fringe
use it to accentuate how scared you are
about something
my hair is crazy to accentuate how
scared I am
see it's crazy crazy hair use it to wake
up your flatmate oh good morning charlie
good morning blow a hair dryer into it
and house add a smoke machine for the
full effect
give it a big hug um share your first
kiss with it
really go on you know you want to that's
the ticket and finally fall in love with
it hey where you going that's the end of
my video of our hair bye
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching Charlie is so cool like
which makes you like cool yeah I can't
get it off
so that's kids